and i think something that has happened  the last couple of years that i have  noticed which i think is powerful  and it is a sea change is that the  consumer has begun  in many ways to perform what i would  call loosely  a cultural audit of companies of brands  and of products and services that they  are asked to support  to buy and the cultural audit goes  something like  for the first time businesses  recognize that there is parity in the  marketplace  parity on price parity on features and  benefits  and the consumer as a result of that has  significant choices  as to what they're going to buy and  support but for the first time they're  asking  questions beyond the characteristics of  the product or the service  they're asking about values they're  asking  questions about how you take care of  your people  whether or not you're giving back to the  community in which they live  and work